malgré la pluie glaciale jésus-crainiens
sont venus faire la queue pour
s'approvisionner en eau dans ses
fontaines publiques encore en marche
dans la capitale plus de la moitié de la
population est privé de courantes
d'électricité et de gaz à l'image
d'Albina seul avec ses deux enfants
c'est comme ça qu'on vit un pull un
deuxième un troisième on vit comme ça
maintenant
heureusement les voisins nous aident je
vais chez celui qui a du gaz et je
cuisine chez lui
des millions d'Ukrainiens subissent des
coupures de courant et les dernières
frappes russes sont endommagées un peu
plus les infrastructures énergétiques
selon le président ukrainien une
quinzaine de régions manquent d'eau et
d'électricité
la situation avec l'électricité reste
difficile dans presque toutes les
régions cependant nous nous éloignons
progressivement des coupures et chaque
heure nous rebranchons l'électricité
pour de nouveaux consommateurs
ouvriers du secteur de l'énergie
employer des services publics
entreprises tout le monde fait sa part
pour redonner de la lumière aux
Ukrainiens
3 centrales nucléaires sous contrôle de
Kiev ont ainsi pu être reconnectés jeudi
les autorités ont aussi mis en place des
centres pour permettre aux Ukrainiens de
se réchauffer de recharger leur
téléphone ou d'avoir un accès à Internet